vous savez quoi je pense que je devrais
faire une vidéo sauf chez oh oui ça
paierait xiaomi a encore frappé parce
que au final c'est un s'installe
tranquillement
c'est un petit peu ce qui se passe avec
ce mini 9 tonne qui n'a 2009 que le nom
puisqu'il ressemble pas vraiment nomi 9
qui sortis à quelques temps le 1907 le
red mica 20 qui a été présenté en chine
mais il ya quelques jours et qui
arrivent en france où le nom 1903 pour
garder un peu l'appellation la marque si
le ce a repéré un peu le client vous
sauriez pas perdu alors que vous voyez
marqué 1900 par sauf que je trouve que
dans l'absolu ça perd un peu à côté de
sa red mica vince aura été aussi
compliqué si on me ya beaucoup de
produits
des fonds ont su faire un petit peu avec
sa vie n'est fait en tout cas shiomi va
sur les grands écrans sans encoches
c'est une nouvelle étape de franchie
sauf que cette fois ci ils vous ont mis
ça je pense que ça vous aura pas échappé
la petite caméra pop up qui se situe
juste là qui sort un peu comme sur le
wan plus c'est trop cette petite caméra
qui est quand même très sympa assez
sécurisé lorsque vous le faites tomber
elle rentre dedans c'est cool c'est
sympa c'est mignon il ya plein de belles
qualités en attendant le deuxième
semestre 2009 ou alors carrément début
2020 avec elle les caméras complètement
intégrée sous l'écran semi 9t écoule
intéressant et pour plusieurs raisons
[Musique]
le minot fesses avant tout un tout
nouveau design par rapport à ce qu'on
peut avoir par rapport au milieu c'est
vraiment aux infos vraiment oublier la
référence mis 9 jeux vous le dis il vole
ont mis ici me 9 t si vous oubliez
miller vous avez vraiment essayé de tout
nouveaux pourrait dire et de mica mince
on veut rester dessus mme bonds en tout
cas il s'appelle quand même mis 9 des
dépenses et un petit peu quand j'en ai
un comme ça au nord view 20 de ce début
d'année avec cet os ddv que vous aviez
mais on a un petit peu cet effet là avec
le côté holographique qui est vraiment
très sympa qui change un peu on retrouve
également par rapport aux 1900 yvan
tuellement la caméra principale qui
entourent ici d'un petit halo
réfléchissant c'est très sympa un dos
bien fini de belles finitions pour voir
qu'on est sur un produit qui n'est
vraiment pas très très très chers petits
boutons ou sur le côté le bouton de
volume on voit là un petit haut parleur
mono de la recharge en usb ses tiroirs
de cartes sim ici petit micro on
retrouve ici sur le côté il ya pas grand
chose sur le dessus la caméra pop up qui
vient se loger juste là ici une prise
jack 3.5 petit micro réduction bout et
puis voyez pas grand chose après le
smartphone est assez minimaliste on a
ici et vous voyez ici
de quoi ouvrir hop avec son empreinte
digitale ça va pas extrêmement vite
néanmoins ça a le mérite d'être là et ça
fonctionne moi ce qui surprendra
toujours avec services et leur capacité
de vous sortir des smartphones avec des
belles finitions comme ça à des tarifs
aussi bas
on commence quand même je vous le dis à
349 euros pour la version 6 giga de ram
64 g le stockage on va rentrer dans le
côté un petit peu plus payent tout à
l'heure vous pouvez même le trouver chez
cdiscount dans des créneaux horaires un
peu particulier à moins de 300 euros et
ça s'est relativement die la force de
frappe de cheyrou mination c'est qu'ils
travaillent avec une marche il n'excède
pas 5%
mais malgré tout voyez vous sortir un
smartphone comme ça avec ses finitions
là avec tout ce travail que dolo
graphique un grand écran amoled de cette
qualité là sans encoches avec une caméra
pop up qui quand même des dernières
technologies de cette année 2010 9
c'est vraiment toujours hallucinant la
force de frappe cachet omis les choix
qu'ils font la stratégie qu'a d'ailleurs
c'est vraiment énorme
il nous sort quand même un écran amoled
qui relativement énorme 6,39 pouces
c'est du fsd plus c'est l'écran qui est
vachement bien calibrée lorsque je vous
conseille quand même c'est d'aller dans
affichage vous allez dans contrastées
couleurs et moi je l'aimé quand même en
show ça casse un petit peu la lumière
bleue font qu'on a un rendu qui est
vraiment bonne qualité vous laisser en
contraste automatique est là
il faut que ça marche bien par défaut
c'est pas mal mais il ya plus de lumière
bleue je pense que c'est plus fatigant
pour l'oeil ça jaunies légèrement en
couleurs chaudes pour venir un petit peu
le le module est là et à mon avis c'est
quand même là vous aurez le meilleur
rendu j'ouvre ma petite caméra pop-up
kokou vous me voyez j'ai vraiment ce
très grand écran qui est entièrement
dégagée et qui ne sert absolument que
d'écran donc fini les encoches on pourra
regretter éventuellement d'avoir bordure
fait quand même un petit peu grande sur
le haut à plus grande sur le bas sur les
côtés bon ça reste quand même pas
hallucinant ça fonctionne c'est bien
mais surtout dites vous bien vous êtes
sur un smartphone à 350 euros
et ça par rapport au positionnement du
produit c'est tout simplement
hallucinant
on est donc sur un produit qui est
vraiment là pour côté multimédia vous
avez netflix qui est installée en natif
donc ça c'est vachement bien que schumi
nous unir enfin netflix de disponible
dans ce smartphone là vous pouvez venir
regarder des séries
côté multimédia s'arrache vachement bien
vous avez vraiment ce très grand écran
qui est vraiment super content à
l'expérience d'immersion et en plus
c'est quand même relativement pas mal
alors bien vous car haut parleur mono
qui sont situées là c'est la fille sauf
qu'ils veulent d'ailleurs vous avez du
gros sel sans voix alors il ya un côté
ap le médium fatalement on est sera un
petit haut parleur de smartphones le
malgré tout y est du son et ça c'est
vachement bien
mais ça ne s'arrête pas là parce que
j'ai omis à intégrer une prise jack jack
3.5 première brancher votre casque au
dessus
l'expérience audio est bien meilleure
qualité la puissance est pas dingue
néanmoins ça marche relativement bien
c'est avec ces pratiques et je vous dis
là on est vraiment heureux smartphones
qui est taillé pour le multimédia très
très très clairement dès lors vous avez
un grand écran comme ça c'est évident
que vous êtes là pour profiter de ce
grand écran de cette élite et de
visionnage tant au niveau de la dalle
amoled que de la surface de visionnage
donc un smartphone taillé pour le
multimédia taillé pour le gaming taillé
pour naviguer sur internet pour profiter
ne pas voir dans le coche pas des coûte
rien qui va venir gêner la n'y a dedans
et en plus vous avez un écran qui est
très lumineux bien calibré de bonne
qualité et croyez-moi si votre titre
vous c'est de regarder des séries de
vous faire plaisir sur les réseaux
sociaux
là dessus vous serez franchement pas
déçu on est vraiment sur un smartphone
qui est complètement optimisé pour le
jeu sur des grands écrans comme ça c'est
hyper hyper hyper hyper hyper hyper
appréciable c'est un dragon 730 marche
très bien
couplé à 6 giga de ram ça ira
parfaitement bien après vous à du
stockage soit 64 go de stockage soit 128
giga de stockage c'est lui et fès 2.1
c'est pas derrière technologie a plu
mais ça marche parfaitement bien là
dessus vous avez absolument aucun
problème à savoir que le teint dragonne
730 devenir optimiser l'autonomie de
votre smartphone d'ailleurs l'autonomie
qui est vraiment excellent vous avez une
grosse batterie de 4000 milliers en
paire d'arrières de la recharge rapide
en 18 watts en usb type c'est ici c'est
une superbe autonomie vous garder
jusqu'à deux jours ça dépend bien
évidemment toujours de votre
consommation mais c'est ça qui est
vraiment appréciable ce smartphone c'est
que vous avez une grande dalle amoled
qui va être bien pas forcément
énergivores puisque vous le savez
françois je vois si vous le savez mais
sur de l'oled sur de la molette bien
évidemment un pixel douar est un fils à
l'étain le fait d'abord reste un dragon
730 qui est grave en guyane au maître
permettre d'optimiser l'autonomie du
smartphone on consomme à 34 millions
perdus en arrière ça vous apporte quand
même de l'autonomie vous avez donc plein
d'éléments qui mis bout à bout font que
vous avez un smartphone qui vraiment
bien qu'une vraie bête de course une
vraie bête de compet qui n'est pas le
plus puissant mais pour les usages que
vous allez en avoir pour du jeu pour des
réseaux sociaux pour des vidéos pour
plein de choses c'est vachement bien et
surtout à moins de 350 euros
c'est un gagnant tout sur ce smartphone
c'est la partie photo vidéo c'est pas
forcément le tout le plus cool sur ce
smartphone 9 mai mais en moins ça marche
pas mal
vous avez à tripoli photo à l'arrière ça
ça ne vous aura pas échappé
vous avez une caméra principale de 48
mégapixels c'est la sony yannick 582 la
petite soeur la sonic 586 vous passez un
petit peu côté technique c'est une
caméra qui permettra de faire des photos
or 48 mégapixels vous avez encore un tel
objectif zoom fois douce et une vie
mégapixels et vous avez une 13
mégapixels et un grand pan de 124 8
degrés à savoir la caméra principale à
sec à capteur de 48,6 elle ouvre à f
1.75 tandis qu'à l'avant ici caché là
dessous vous avez un capteur de 20 méga
pixels ce qui est assez rigolo c'est que
je suis emmerdé j'enlève mon petit micro
de se rapprocher shiomi
il nous a complètement fait un petit
bruit lorsqu'on l'ouvré lorsqu'on a fait
écouter
il existe donc plusieurs bruits avoir
lequel vous préférez aussi une petite
lumière qui est adjointe lavoyer aux
petites lumières bleues il y en a aussi
une petite lumière rouge qui existe et
du point de vue logiciel ce qui est
assez marrant c'est que vous avez
plusieurs possibilités labo photo
principale ça nous ferait photo 12
mégapixels peut le faire les photons 48
mégapixels si vous le souhaitez pour
vraiment venir forcer le mode 40 8
mégapixels après le mode portrait de
nuit panorama bon tout ça je vous le
passez on est aussi un mode panorama que
la caméra de celle fille
c'est vraiment gadget mais si vous
voulez le faire vous pouvez le faire
c'est une évidence sur ses smartphones
c'est l'heure vous avez beaucoup de
lumière ça marche parfaitement bien
déguisé moins de lumière il est quand
même un petit peu moins à l'aise là vous
êtes sur le capteur principal l'a48
mégapixels le rendu des couleurs est
assez honnête c'est elle c'est juste
assez correct on y arrive en titre sur
le zoom x 2 ça fonctionne également de
la même manière et la grand-angle ça
marche si l'on voyait des câbles
beaucoup de lumière tout de suite rendu
qui est de bonne qualité qui est assez
agréable même sur une jolie petite fleur
comme ça dans les 112 x 2 voies y est on
a quand même des couleurs qui sont assez
juste assez préservé assez cohérente par
rapport à ce qu'on peut trouver sur la
caméra principale et sur le grand temps
que tu sais un petit peu déformant c'est
un peu moins agréable alors sur ces
petits pots logis de photos c'est
beaucoup plus lisse et le rendu est
quand même moins qu'elle y met une fois
de plus on va surtout l'utiliser pour
avoir des effets pour pouvoir faire
rentrer pas mal de potes dans le maine
plan là je vous avais pareil le même
plan photo caméra principale zoom x 2
c'est un petit peu moins vers avec ça
peut plus être plus marc renaud milieu
beaucoup plus clair ici et là je très
grand-angle
les couleurs sont pas tout à fait les
mêmes de cette manière là pareil caméra
principale le zoom x 2 et la très grand
temps qui est légèrement plus déformant
la même chose ici
voyez bon dans l'absolu ça fait la faire
là une photo sans la caméra de celle
fille qui fait franchement le job
soumah c'est correct la nisa pas que
j'ai une tête qui est absolument
horrible vous êtes sur le le mode
portrait qui fait assez bien la faire au
niveau du détourage même au niveau des
cheveux on voyait ce assez juste et là
on arrive sur les photos ne nuit
absolument aucune hummer dans le studio
forcément il va souffrir un petit peu
plus on va monter en disant on va
récupérer beaucoup de bruit c'est
beaucoup moins qualitatif
il a même chose photo nuit avec le zoom
x 2 voies y aurait pu faire beaucoup
beaucoup de bruit soyons très clairs si
vous cherchez ce photophone avec ce
smartphone vous risquez moment des déçus
si par contre vous vous dites je veux un
excellent smartphone avec toutes les
qualités je vous ai cité juste avant et
qu'en plus de ça vous voulez des photos
du bonne facture
notamment lorsque vous avez beaucoup
lumière il fait franchement le jeune le
décret met en lumière il est moins
performant
le grand angle c'est complètement ouf
mais ça nous permettra d'avoir des
effets sympa le zoom x 2 et au nec
on a vraiment un smartphone qui est
parfaitement honnête en termes de photos
qui n'est pas absolument hallucinant
dans cette petite caméra pop up ya un
effet un peu waouh ça c'est assez cool
c'est vraiment je trouve en tout cas
pour moi un smartphone qui est vraiment
bien
et surtout à son positionnement
tarifaire parce que comme je le disais
la version 6 giga de ram 64 giga le
stockage est à 349 euros pour cette
qualité de smartphones et si giga de ram
128 go de stockage à 389 euros c'est
vraiment ouf on est vraiment sur l'idée
en tout cas du plus rarement d'avis
flactif killers est très très belles
bêtes très belle finition le dos là je
ne sais pas si vous aimez dit que le
moindre commentaire
moi je trouve ça c'est cool et puis le
fait d'avoir cette caméra pop-up
comptant notamment sur moins de +7
promet qu'il ramène beaucoup plus cher
alors on va pas comparer ce qui n'est
pas comparable parce qu'il ya quand même
un monde entre le one piece est trop
avec son écran qui est juste hallucinant
qui en plus en usb 3.0 au niveau de
l'écriture enfin est-ce que taux de
choses mais ce smartphone là avec les
qualités avec ce qui vous propose avec
la fiche technique derrière qui est
solide avec le rendu que vous avez c'est
vraiment un excellent produit que je
trouve vraiment bien et en plus de ça
ils ont loupé alors spa pour push est
loupé mais c'est pour vous le dire ils
ont eu nos pères et que cdiscount
alors c'est également des critères un
très particulière il faut être là
connectés dulin le lundis et les jeudis
de 17h à 22h sur le site de cdiscount
sur des quantités limitées
je passe il ya encore de quoi il était
la semaine dernière à 299 euros
c'est-à-dire ce smartphone là à moins de
300 euros ça clairement c'est un coup
marketing c'est une vraie opération de
com de la part des ja de cdiscount mais
surtout de xiaomi de pouvoir sortir ce
smartphone là à mon avis ils gardent
plus de marge à 299 euros
je sais pas ce qu'il leur reste qu'en
marge derrière pour gagner leur vie mais
en tout cas c'est une belle balle au pc
un bon coup de com on en parlera pour
twitch en train de vous en parler entre
poids il faut savoir que je suis vous
n'avez absolument aucune certification
nil certification ip67 ni certification
ip 68 ans si vous savez pas ce sont ces
certifications là sont des
certifications temps des fêtes ification
c'est dur à prononcer quand on parle
comme ça sur des certifications pour
l'étanchéité résistant à la poussière et
à l'eau là vous n'avez pas de
certification pour deux raisons
principales à mon avis la première c'est
une certification ça coûte à peu près 20
euros par smartphone donc imaginer sur
des masses production ça coûte quand
même tout petit relativement cher et
quand vous savez que si on me tire les
prix vers le bas
je dirais que tout ce qui peut être
gagner en termes de coûts de production
doit l'être ça c'est le premier point
est le deuxième point c'est que de toute
façon avec ce système de caméra pop up
ce sont des smartphones qui ne sont pas
certifiés abl il ya exactement la même
chose sur le one + 7 pro donc on
prouve exactement le même cas de figure
sur ce smartphone là si vous voulez ce
smartphone avec le top des performances
c'est pas là dessus qu'il faut aller
mais si vous voulez un très bon
smartphone avec de bonnes performances
un très bel écran bien calibré sens
absolument aucune encoches avec une
grande dimension qui se tient bien une
main et que vous avez surtout utilisé à
demain avec des caméras qui sont cora
qui font le job même s'ils ne sont pas
complètement folle et bien là dessus à
349 euros elle pas vous plantez parce
que je trouve vraiment bien je sais pas
ce que vous en pensez comment vous
trouvez en bas en commentaire vous
marquez tout ça quels sont pour vous les
points positifs points négatifs qu'est
ce qui vous donne envie qu est ce qui
vous ferait hésiter
vous pouvez y aller en tout cas ce qui
est cool c'est que chez sony continue sa
progression ça fait à peine un an à
peine plus de nord qui sont arrivés en
france et ils sont toujours encore plus
agressif encore plus performant avec des
smartphones qui sont hyper cool beaucoup
de lancements ou grosse actu donc on va
continuer en parallèle je vous invite
donc d'ailleurs dès maintenant à vous
abonner comme ça vous saurez tout sur
l'actu oui s'il vous botte il ya un lien
dans la description et moi vous embrasse
à demain ciao